I am absolutely delighted to to be the
moderator on this panel our second sort
of substantive panel where we are
looking at signs and instances of
democratic erosion our first speaker is
Nancy Bermejo
from na field College Oxford and
Princeton University and we will pretty
much have the same set up so if you can
speak for you know 10 12 minutes each
and then we will go to some questions at
the end
Thanks and I'm pleased to have studied
without stepping so i endorse what our
students at earlier today and I'm very
very glad to be here and very glad to
see y'all doing what it should do and
reach out to the real real politics
around us anyway I've been in England
for a long time and my British
colleagues often read papers and it's an
efficient way to get a lot said in a
short amount of time so that's what I'm
going to do how did democracies fall
apart the truth is that they never do
falling apart implies the process devoid
of will driven by gravitational forces
but regime change is always the result
of deliberate action democracies don't
fall apart they're taken apart by
counter elites so will it happen here do
the ominous parallels between the rise
of interwar fascism for child tragedy as
people sometimes discussing here since
we can learn from success as well as
failure I'm going to trace the
trajectory of failed democracy and into
worried Italy an enduring democracy and
interwar Finland
putting our current democracy and
comparative perspective reveal some
troubling similarities and some
consoling contrast Italy story is one of
capitalist fascist alliance
ill-conceived
invitations and a weak defense the hopes
and fears inspired by the Bolsheviks
revolution and its success in Russia
played a pivotal role in the breakdown
of the Italian democracy in 1922
Mussolini was spectacularly successful
in using the seizure of factors and
farms and the threat of revolution as a
means of mobilizing support landowners
and industrial elites joined Mussolini
in common cause and his fascist squads
man by veterans provided the property
protections and the coercion that the
new democratic order failed to provide
together a fascist capitalist alliance
helped undermine the liberal state
fearing the left himself
Italy's liberal Prime Minister Joly T
invited the fascist party to join the
electoral list of the national block a
coalition of parties united in
opposition to socialism the invitation
gave the fascists an air of legitimacy
and 6% of the seats in the legislature
it was followed by an even more
consequential invitation when King
Victor Emmanuel asked for Cellini to
form government the elected elite who
should have defended italy's democratic
institutions failed miserably their
rampant corruption boosted disaffection
and provided mussolini with a ready
audience key leaders simply beat a
retreat as the fascists grew stronger do
you lead to himself resigned and stayed
out of Rome during the entire crisis and
parliamentarians simply avoided key
votes and debates finally Italy's chief
military commander refused to commit his
forces to resistance when the King asked
if he could repeal Mussolini's advance
Italian democracy was left defenseless
Finland's success was based on a dearth
of fascist dollars successful exclusion
and a broad defensive Finnish democracy
endured the assault of a movement
inspired by Italian
fascism the extreme right lapa movement
emerged when anti-communist farmers
reeling from the depression rioted in
1929 and it swept the country so quickly
that the breakdown of democracy seemed
to certainty at first political elites
made concessions to the movement passing
anti-communist laws and overlooking
extreme right lawlessness and violence
but by the autumn of 1932 crackdown the
courts meted out harsh punishments for
movement violence and even convicted a
leaders son of political murder the
conservative agrarian union party turned
decisively against the movement in 1930
unlike its counterparts in Italy it
elide with the Social Democrats and two
other moderate parties to exclude
extremists and form a lawfulness front
as its coalition malapa movement soon
lost nearly all of support from economic
elites when the movement organized a
revolt in 1932 the conservative
president PE FINA fund he is arrested
its leaders and made a radio peal urging
its members to go home as a well-known
nationalist hero himself from the Civil
War but once had support within the
movement Savina who might well have
behaved as Victor Emmanuel did in Italy
but instead he outlawed the movement all
together working together Finnish
political military and economic elites
kept Finnish democracy alive so what
does this comparison which might seem
curious here today what does this
compare us and teach us finners
democracy endured because it's political
elites marshaled what I've called
elsewhere something called distancing
capacity distancing involves condemning
and prosecuting all those who engage in
violence
Ollis nests or in our case violations of
the Constitution even when they present
themselves as allies in Finland
political parties conservative political
parties courts and capitalists and a
conservative war hero succeeded in
distancing the right from
anti-democratic forces and thereby
preserving the system now might we see a
process approximating distancing here
I'm not going to push a parallel between
Spain of ruin and John McCain McCain
wasn't wielding presidential power when
his own process of distancing began and
Trump has already been invited to rule
without a king and we see the very
opposite of distancing often in Congress
this said there might be reasons to
expect more successful distancing in the
future I discussed several in the paper
but here I have time for only two and
the first involves the differing role of
economic elites distancing was unlikely
in Italy because a critical mass of
fearless of fearful economic elites
believed that democracy could not serve
their interests but US Capitol has done
spectacularly well under liberal
democracy they don't need any thuggery
or anti system action they're in control
of the system we heard that this morning
unions have been so weakened that they
hardly pose a threat to profits much
less prosperity anarchists a few a
number and despite blatant deadly
provocations mobilizations in defense of
minority rights have involved only
minimal violence and it's rarely
property related this is astounding
rather than colluding with trunk many of
the most dynamic and powerful sectors of
our capitalist elite have emerged to
oppose his policies
they don't fear a redistributive left
instead they fear tariff walls that will
raise their cost of production they fear
losing valuable members of their
workforce because of the xenophobic
immigration laws they fear losing market
share if their association with Trump's
racism or anti-semitism leads to
consumer boycotts and surely many fear
violating their own democratic
principles so we're not seeing a sweet
capitalist alliance here we're seeing
the seeds of distancing instead so if
powerful economic elites or some
powerful economic elites can distance
themselves from trump in anti-democratic
initiatives can political elites follow
suit or should they like party elites in
Italy assume that they need to support
Trump and anti-democratic actions to win
elections well maybe distancing is
impossible here we read that moderate
Republican elites are running scared
and that Bannon and the Mercer's are
waging successful war on the Republican
establishment but a closer look at
political behavior and opinion reveals
that the incentives for some form of
distancing might still exist for
observations motivate my hope with this
conclusion first Trump might bear some
resemblance to Mussolini but I'm not
sure Trump himself believes an actual
movement he has only a base and that's
different the dynamism that we saw in
the interwar years even the dynamism
we've seen more recently with leaders
like Chavez or Korea simply it's simply
not there the abysmal turnout for his
inauguration provides evidence of my
point this is a movement
this is a movement this is probably not
a and keep in mind that Trump's charisma
is not transferable think about past
affection the people and causes he backs
often fail Trump supposed supporters and
allies have often been fickle friends
and this lowers the cost of imposing his
anti-democratic initiative public
opinion trends provide further
incentives for distancing positive
opinions of Trump as we heard earlier
today have been declining since January
25th and a full 30 percent of
Republicans not us in this room a thirty
percent of Republicans saying that they
agree with him on a few or no issues and
only a third of Republicans say that
they actually like the way that Donald
Trump conducts himself as president is
this because so many Republicans stand
on trump's right must would be distance
nurse here simply shut up and move right
or lose office perhaps not despite
polarization the proportion of Americans
who deem themselves consistently
conservative is still only 10% they
simply seem more numerous because
they're so visible in the media and so
visible in primaries polarization has
definitely taken place all of the
literature shows us that especially the
asite that Adam gave us earlier but
there's still a center there's still a
center there's still a lot of people who
aren't on the very farm right the
mention of primaries and elections
brings me to a second set of data that
might reveal incentives for distance
inez a nes data suggests that the
strongest predictor of Trump votes was
right-wing ideology
not a big surprise but if we look over
time the trends in right-wing ideology
are highly volatile and actually
decreasing so there's a vulnerability
there
moreover anti-immigrant sentiment has
declined steadily and decisively that's
good news these trends might make
distancing possible if politicians can
succeed in exploiting the third
incentive for distancing is the fact
that support for basic democratic
institutions remains very strong here
and we heard that earlier today the vast
majority of American 74 percent still
believe that the rights of people with
unpopular views should be protected
seventy-nine percent still believe that
people have the right to nonviolent
protest and eighty-nine percent agree
that strong democracy depends on
national elections that are open and
fair even though our troubled
legislature might seem to parallel Italy
under G Lethe 83 percent of Americans
still believe that strong democracy
requires a system of checks and balances
83 percent so these data make me think
that at the national level at least
elected elites can distance themselves
from Trump and Marshall an effective
defense of democratic institutions with
public support and if I'm right in
assuming the Trump's base is largely
populist and not literally fascist the
challenge of keeping mainstream parties
a lot is diminished and there are all
kinds of institutional reasons for that
as well
the key though is to get a broader
sector of the electorate to vote in
primaries and in elections so improving
that miserable 55 percent turnout we had
in the last election as a place to start
so a quick return to interwar
comparisons will highlight my very
tentative conclusion here the actions of
the most dynamic sectors of American
Plus at least some core aspects of
American public make me think that the
parallels with Finland are much stronger
than those with Italy Trump's support
with key economic elites is precarious
and it's possible that their
mobilization and an alliance with
democracy preserving political elites
would prevent further backsliding Alando
by noting that every unhappy democracy
is unhappy in its own way and that the
scripts for transitions for democracy
are infinite it's possible that identity
politics or some other factor that I've
neglected entirely today will enable
Trump to stave off distancing and take
our democracy part but for now I think
we should all be consoled by the
contrast with interwar Italy thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Nancy
our next speaker is an aggressive small
abu say and i have for years been
butchering her names
so I am going to be both less optimistic
and more parochial as I usually a.m.
and I'll offer examples rather than the
kind of sophisticated analogies that it
doesn't talk really mostly about to
Poland and Hungary and I'll try to make
three points the one the first Western
briefly described what the rise of
authoritarian populism has been like in
Hungary and Poland to show you some of
the institutional damage and the
rewriting of history that occurs and
three and this is where I get really
pessimistic sure that there's been very
little in the way of constraint of this
processes so first what are these
populist look like well this is our
friend Viktor Orban from the Hungarian
Fidesz party known as the party of Young
Democrats which picket and it basically
is one of the sort of the stalwarts in
the heroes of the communism of the
collapse of communism 89 but becomes a
conservative populist party in the 1990s
it experiences City gains in the 2000s
and as you can see this is a percentage
of the seats that it holds in the
Hungarian Parliament it basically holds
over two-thirds of the seats starting in
2010 and that will turn out to be a very
important number in Poland you have
peace he represented by its leader
Joseph Kosinski the placement of that
crown is not incidental this is a party
that is both conservative and populist
from the start and two years ago and
wins 38 percent of the vote which gives
it more than half of the seats in
parliament and the reason why these
parties arise the reason why voters plug
for this authoritarian populist is
basically because of the weakness of
mainstream parties the incumbents the
Socialists in the and hungry basically
admit to have lied about the state of
the economy a secret tape comes to light
and they basically have in that tape the
Prime Minister minutes that we have and
I quote live day and night about how bad
the state of the economy is in Poland
similarly you have the previous centrist
party that governs Padma which basically
umbrella starts to rely on what what is
known as the politics of warm water
we're basically on the taps run there's
nothing really off on offer from the
part of you whatsoever and so voters get
both bored and
somewhat disgusted with some taping
scandals that occurred the problem is
that there are no other real
alternatives for the voters
it's either these populist or it's the
discredited mainstream parties so this I
would argue is less a weakness of
democracy in these countries then
basically this party competition at this
particular point in time which the
populist both criticize and benefit from
now the significance of the populist
coming to power is that the numbers that
they achieved that discussed with the
mainstream parties was so big that feeis
gains that 2/3 of the seats which gives
it a constitutional supermajority it is
now basically free to rewrite the
Constitution as it sees fit in Poland
for the first time the governing party
can govern without cumbersome coalition
partners and in Poland having coalition
partner basically is no Doom's the
government which gives both of these
parties enormous discretion discretion
that they immediately start to make use
of and are basically follows is a set of
templates there's almost an
institutional template that both of
these parties fought once in office
there's no moderation through inclusion
just because they start to govern they
don't become responsible governments and
they basically both start to implement
this template for dismantling formal
institution and of basically undermining
the informal norms and values of
democracy so when it comes to formal
institutions the reason why I say
there's a template is because both
parties follow the exact same sequence
and this exact same targets basically
they should totally share the same
pattern of both sequencing and targeting
the first target are the courts in both
cases that party seek to end judicial
economy by packing the courts and
restricting their domains over which
they can act imposing term limits
instead of basically lifetime terms and
so on on both the supreme court and on
the lower bodies in Hungary
one official conveniently the wife of
the number two party leader becomes the
person in charge of all judicial
appointments at all levels of government
so it's an incredible politicization of
the one main check on government power
in a parliamentary system or we see next
are attacks on the media as being
unpatriotic
being picked newsy and so on followed by
formal constraints by basics of near
limiting in some cases basically heavily
taxing the media forcing it to register
imposing regulations on what canon can't
report the next target our civil society
ranging from nongovernmental
organizations to churches and
universities which now again have to
undergo onerous registration
requirements are classified as foreign
agents in the cases of NGOs and so on
the whole sort of witch-hunt of George
Soros has to be seen in this light right
this is basically he becomes the one of
the first targets of the Hungarian
government and then the government's go
after the legal framework and here the
fact that foetus and hungry houses
two-thirds supermajority allows it to
rewrite the Constitution entirely and it
relights the Constitution in a ways that
not only favored in the short term but
favor in the long term as well so for
example the new constitution now
includes supermajority requirements on
even simple legislature such as budgets
which means that even if fetus is ever
in the opposition it can effectively act
as a veto player and an eto point on all
subsequent governments that exist in
Hungary there's also of course
gerrymandering with massive changes in
the electoral laws to favor in the
existing existing party and it shirts
for the incumbency and finally in both
countries we see attempts to rule by law
so we see basically targeted and
retroactive justice where analysis
especially there are lost targeted at
individuals and that are attractive in
their administration but formal
situations aren't the only thing that
matter in democracies these parties also
attack the informal institutions the
first thing they do is to basically
exclude the political opposition
so in these parliamentary regimes the
political opposition parties have
traditionally been included in all kinds
of oversight and ethics committees and
it's seen serve as an informal norm that
you do that to make those committees let
it basically give the greater legitimacy
this they are now excluded from the
ethics and oversight committees the
opposition basically is no longer
allowed to participate in those when it
comes to the media what now happens is
basically the government will buy the
large Swain's of ads and of CERCLA and
channel a channel funding only to
government is to me yet a basely favor
the government and they basically in
effect starve other newspapers and other
media of of advertising new revenue
there's also a total sub abnegation of
informal accountability I'm Anna Pollan
and Holly there's less worry about
publishing the president's tax returns
than there is about publishing the full
lists of donors to the political parties
a lot of those that have now become
entirely opaque and we're no longer sure
quite exactly who's funding these
parties or how they're using more
importantly state resources to fund
themselves and finally what these gov
governments have also done is to fund
all kinds of friendlier organizations
all kind of all kinds of astroturfing
they have funded all kinds of funds to
party allies directly from the state
violating these informal norms of
basically fiduciary duty to the state
and what also happens in Poland Hungary
is sort of a politics of memory and
identity a rewriting of history to favor
the current governments so there's a
rejection of the communist past and the
Communist Party successors and
politicians as inevitably tainted right
in Poland there's this whole story that
aphromoo that not the entire democracy
after 1989 has been tainted by the round
table agreements between the Communist
Party and the opposition back in 89 but
the entire Democratic the system is
tainted by these communist leftovers
that have to be extirpated there's a
division of society into good and bad
the Polish the heiress of Kartini whom
you saw earlier actually talked of a
worst kind of polls referring to those
who don't support the party and there's
the institutionalization of these this
is you know the this is the hungarian
house of terror as it's known its amid
giant museum that's erected on the site
of the former Arrow Cross fascist
movements headquarters where basically
the argument is made that communism and
fascism are one and the same thing and
they are both based in these taints on
Hungarian history the exhibit that you
see there of course is cutting which is
a reference to the murder by Soviet
officers served by the Soviet army of
Polish officers during World War two so
there's also some yogurt evidence over
sort of a sympathetic
similar I want to Poland as well and as
if all this weren't enough there's
evidence that the two parties have
coordinated their leaders have met at
multiple meetings sort of multiples of
note for our meetings help between the
party leaders they follow the same
template they support each other in the
international arena and they continually
refer as having a shared vision of what
you're about to look like and what their
countries have to look like and here
this is exemplified by of course a
Polish right-wing newspaper cover in
basically on your orbit and Kochanski
they are defending Europe against the
madness of the left-wing politics and
Islam business the terror is the equator
so what are the constraints on all this
well unfortunately they're proving to be
pretty weak the EU the European Union
which has somewhat castigated these
parties has proved largely perilous and
that's because fetus belongs to the
European People's Party which also
counts among its members the German
Christian Democrats and several other
prominent parties and that party is
basically blocked sanctioning of Hungary
and turn Hungary has blocked the
sanctioning of Poland and as repeatedly
said it will repeat Oh any moves to
sanction Poland within that it countries
themselves the opposition parties are
highly fragmented they you know they to
suffer from this inability to coordinate
and to offer some kind of incredible
alternative to the ruling parties and so
they're really the only two things that
constrain them are basically the the
twofold the first of this is that
wealthiest and peace while these two
parties share the same commitments it
can be safely said that the Polish party
has half the competence of the Hungarian
one so you know the Hungarian party's BC
led by a bunch of lawyers and they have
systematically done everything that a
bunch of lawyers would do they pass
enabling loss they came up they're
carefully chained to check the
legislation they cross every eye and
they dot every T anyway this is my
second language
they're very very careful about the
process by which they enact this erosion
of democracy in Poland in contrast the
governing party has now for example send
conflicting the conflicting versions of
the same law to the Senate and to the
lower house of parliament it's unable to
keep a straight story about what's going
on it has consistently basically fallen
all over itself in an attempt to around
democracy in Poland so this is one place
where you're the lack of competence at
least in the Polish case may prove a
constraint on their designs on democracy
the second force that has intermittently
been helpful is civil society and civil
society has not been able to for example
stop the erosion of judicial economy it
has not been able to stop the rewriting
of the constitutions or the electoral
laws but it has on specific occasions
been able to generate enough pressure
for the government to basically hold
back and that's the case for example of
the ever-increasing structures on
abortion laws in Poland where there was
a massive black protests of women you
know this is held in the rain last
October that recently brought is saw
hundreds of thousands of people coming
out to the streets in defense of the
status quo or in the Hungarian case
the protest against for example the the
shutting down of the Central European
University the one sort of autonomous
university left in Hungary so there is
some grounds for hope here but
unfortunately you know in contrast to to
Nancy's eloquent you know somewhat
shaded optimism the situation in Poland
Hungary is basically not looking well at
all
thank you next up is Susan Hyde great
good morning everyone
or yes still morning got in very in the
wee hours continued even it's a true
honor to participate in this panel and
to be back here at Yale I spent the
first decade of my career here and I
taught my very first lecture from this
very spot when I was the 27 year old
assistant professor so I'm especially
pleased to be to be have the opportunity
to be back here I mentioned that I'm now
at UC Berkeley which is one of the
campuses that has recently experienced
pretty significant efforts to Bates I
think the campus community into a
reaction that will gain national and
international attention we have had
quite a bit of I guess we'll call it
security concrete barriers on campus
streets bomb squads on active duty on a
regular basis dozens if not hundreds of
police patrolling campus events and what
appears to be lone controversial
speakers in the central part of campus
surrounded by throngs of what appeared
to be amateur journalists armed with
cell phone cameras on selfie sticks and
they are are mobbing the speakers who
again are I think trying to provoke a
reaction and so I end that just in
passing but more generally I want to say
that I am on this panel and my expertise
comes not from a deep knowledge of
specific countries as a true comparative
historico story enlike the the other
individuals on this panel but primarily
from a focus on international relations
and on international efforts to promote
democracy around the world as well as
documentation of efforts by elites to
resist pro-democracy pressures so the
resistance to efforts to promote
democracy is something I
been interested in I'm going to remind
folks of something that I think has been
on the table in much of the conversation
already today and in some of the many
memos that were circulated in advance
which is that democracy has dominated as
a globally promoted and accepted form of
governance not because it is perfect or
because it without fail elects the best
leaders or even very good leaders all of
the time but because it is supposed to
be self-correcting and potentially
self-enforcing mistakes in one electoral
cycle can be corrected in subsequent
electoral cycles this is the
self-correcting mechanism and there are
commonly understood expectations already
referenced several times today for
regularized behavior like periodic
elections that create the conditions for
citizens to enforce democracy or for
other political actors to enforce
democracy the bright lines referenced by
by the organization sponsoring this
conference bright line watch I agree
with the sentiment expressed in some of
the memos most clearly by Adam cherski
that history may not be a good guide to
the present in the US case that it's I
struggled when I was sitting down to
write this I've been thinking about
exactly which cases I should talk about
in terms of specific instances of
democratic erosion and we we just don't
know I guess is my room or I don't know
any other people on the panel probably
no but I I don't know and I use this as
partial justification for my slight
deviation from our assigned questions
for this panel just just slightly so it
is nearly a point of faith or was a
point of faith I guess when I was in
coursework in graduate school that that
developed democracies do not die yet
here we are having this this exact
conversation all of what follows this is
basically speculation a number of
reasons have already been proposed today
and in the memos as to why democratic
erosion might currently be at work in
the US and I will underscore that
populism a point already made has it
many times in history been a very useful
and powerful tool for autocrats to take
power through democratic means I want to
focus on and really underscore two other
processes or mechanisms that I know a
number of would-be autocrats have
exercised in the past while seeking to
make their regimes more autocratic in
practice sometimes while preserving the
veneer of of democracy at the same time
both of these I can imagine quite being
being quite consequential in the u.s.
and in fact we're just mentioned by by
vana and her remarks as well the first
is the role that the media plays or more
precisely that shared information or
common knowledge plays in allowing
democracy to have these two purported
purported advantages that I mentioned at
the beginning of being self correcting
and self-enforcing democracies have and
I'm not just talking about media freedom
or media oppression right there's
something else afoot right now in the
way in which citizens are accessing
information democracies as we all know
have elected many many terrible leaders
some of them were would-be
authoritarians yet the general idea is
that unlike in democracy when bad
leaders can often only be ushered out
via extra constitutional means and often
through their own death or poor health
and democracy bad leaders or bad parties
can be ushered out within constitutional
provisions they're elected all the time
yet we think we can get rid of them
there are also regularly expected
elections and sometimes other events
that provide routine focal points for
collective action and defense of
democracy by either civil society the
judiciary or other actors who are able
to take relevant actions to defend
democracy although you know depending on
the actor of the circumstances are
slightly different
I suspect we all already know this but I
summarize this Locke logic in order to
emphasize what I think most people who
have written about democracy as
potentially self-correcting and
self-enforcing have assumed which is
basically some level of information
transmission amongst the general
population or at least a sizable group
of the general population that that may
be lacking in the u.s. today or that may
be eroding in the u.s. today there is
some possibility there must be some
possibility for a democracy to be
self-correcting and democracy to be self
enforcing for the the potential of the
existence of a sufficient degree of
common knowledge to allow citizens not
only to agree that something is wrong
but to also understand that other
potentially diverse groups of citizens
feel the same way and are likely to do
something about it so here I am
borrowing heavily from some of the
luminaries in the room but I think it's
worth worth emphasizing the state of
media and information consumption among
us among citizens in the u.s. today is
potentially distinctive polarized and
and doesn't require cracking down on the
media for this mechanism to be less
operationalized right that this
mechanism that I'm talking about maybe
is undermined by simply patterns in
consumption of information and I'm this
is this is speculation again but I think
these current pattern patterns of
information consumption have already
undermined the ability of citizens to
play their parts in democracy in in
either voting bad leaders out of office
or perhaps more crucially being able to
play their role in self-enforcing
democracy which requires both that they
value democracy and are willing to
defend it against potential seizures of
power by authoritarian rulers so if the
bright line were obviously crossed and
there was a clear focal point there are
a few things would also logically have
to be true for self-enforcing democracy
to operate and those are the things that
I think I am most worried about today
this is again repeating some of what and
just underscoring what others have
already said and what others are going
to say the current informational
environment might be a symptom rather
than a cause but if it is sticky if it
is path dependent my concern is that it
will make it very difficult in the
future for these mechanism
to operate for democracy to be
self-correcting and self-enforcing on a
practical level you know specific
examples have already been mentioned but
we know that something like this was
definitely afoot in Venezuela in the
early 2000s the the polarization of
information consumption by the citizenry
there was extraordinarily polarized and
there was an inability of citizens to to
understand anything that seemed like
they were experiencing the same reality
the other mechanism that I'm going to
just mention briefly that we have seen
before
and that may be a growing concern in the
US but is also sometimes a potential
source of hope is the independence of
the judiciary long game autocrats ones
who wish to come to power and erode
democracy in their country we have seen
individuals like Daniel Ortega of
Nicaragua comes to mind I would call him
a long game autocrat he understood that
the judiciary under a constitutional
democracy is a constant threat to their
ability to do what they want he was
elected president in 2006 I believe
without much direct manipulation of the
election itself in part because he had
spent at least a decade working with his
allies to ensure that the judiciary
would be aligned with him in support or
at least not oppose the reforms that
were necessary to allow him to be
elected president with a sort of small
plurality of the vote and and to
continue to rule indefinitely which I
think that we're seeing here I'm not
sure that we're on the cusp of that here
but the behavior of the judiciary and
other other actors within the giotto
Sharri and their willingness to step in
to defend democracy when bright lines
are crossed is something to pay
attention to and stacking the judiciary
has certainly been a potential mechanism
of slow and gradual Democratic erosion
I'm going to that that's ten minutes I
have lots of other things to say I want
to just mention two things very quickly
one is that one thing we have already
seen is and this started under Obama I
believe a dramatic decline
and the USS commitment to being a
democracy as an example and as a
supporter of democracy in other
countries around the world this is
something that I have seen very acutely
in my own work and I think that that can
have reinforcing patterns over time that
end up undermining the notion that
citizens would come out to defend
democracy if we are less if democ being
a democracy is less part of the national
identity that we all share then I think
it is less likely that citizens will
come out to defend it and that will have
reinforcing implications for many other
countries in the world so to conclude
I'll just make one other point which is
that I'm sort of returned to one of the
big motivating questions for the
conference that we were sent which was
whether a powerful individual in one
country can undermine can threaten
democracy and so I I'm not I'm still not
sure right it depends on how everyone it
reacts to that individual so if at the
very least is something that requires
passivity on the part of the citizenry
but one point of hope is is that within
a democracy within a country that
already has democratic institutions an
individual or small group of individuals
can also help activate the institutional
constraints that are supposed to trigger
self-enforcing democracy and so thinking
about who those individuals are and what
they might do and how they might speak
to the broader population in a way that
allows people to listen across a variety
of currently siloed sources of
information I think is something to
devote some time and energy to going
forward
[Applause]
yes we have Daniel's a blot next I
realize I've been remiss I've but not
been giving people's institutional
affiliations Daniel is a professor of
government at Harvard thank you
it's wonderful to be here my comments
are going to be drawing on a book that
I've just completed it's coming out in
January
with a title that's very similar to one
of the panels the last panel it's called
how democracies die it's coming out in
January with Steve Levitsky who wanted
to be here but couldn't be here so I'm
gonna draw on some of the ideas from
that obviously not summarize all of the
ideas but in that book we really draw on
the lessons of nineteen thirty some of
the cases that Nancy talks about in
Europe Latin America the 1960s and 70s
and contemporary cases as well this
really feels almost like a summit of
people I've been in communication with
you know over the last year virtually
and think you know and just and you know
you know seeing people's tweets and
Facebook posts and so it's really
wonderful to be in the same room with
everybody so again there's lots of
things I could have talked about but
what I wanted to do was to draw on
really one theme from the book and
that's a theme that John Kerry mentioned
at the outset invited us to think about
norm breaking and how to think about
norm breaking and I wanted to kind of
spend my time just give you some remarks
and thoughts on Norma Rosen and norm
breaking so a lot of us who look at the
u.s. situation are fairly convinced I
think that a serious threat as Donald
Trump is the problem in American
democracy runs much deeper Donald Trump
is the outcome of a long process or
symptom of a deeper problem the problems
in American democracy long precede him
will probably long outlast him so that
in this intuition is kind of feeling
that there's something deeper wrong
really comes from I think partly the
idea that one of the deeper sources of
problems in American democracy and an
indication of trouble in american
democracies that is the growing
intensity and frequency over the last 25
years of democratic norm breaking or
normal erosion so what is worrying is
less the outright violation of
democratic norms and even in the first
year the trump presidency i think and
and what's more worrying is the breaking
of democratic norms then breaking of
unwritten rules and so we worry about
this I think
because when we look around the world
and look at other countries we know that
the death of democracy is often preceded
by the breaking of in words and deeds of
democratic norms
so it's ominous of course when we know
that political leaders and actors
threatened to lock each other up attack
the free media and other neutral
institutions like courts and
bureaucracies it's all deeds also are
frightening when politicians use
constitutional procedures to the hilt in
a dangerous game of political escalation
these two are worrying signs so in other
countries court packing or the
impeachment of as Beatrice mentioned the
peach and Pietschmann of judges of
presidents and so on that are often very
legal these kind of violations of
democratic norms are also worrying so
I'll speak before both Steve Levitsky
and I I think when I say that we are
both convinced that was protected
democracies historically in the US and
elsewhere is less the formal system of
checks and balances within political
systems and more often than norms
underpinning these political
institutions so of course the US
political system that checks and
balances have been pretty effective over
the last hundred years I would say not
the last 200 years over the last hundred
years but these checks and balances
aren't self enacting they're only
effective when reinforced and embedded
in robust democratic norms so in our
book we want to kind of dig into this
idea of democratic norms and to think a
bit harder about what precisely we're
talking about when we talk about
democratic norms why what what is it
that's being undermined and why is this
happening so we think there are really
two master norms that are really worth
thinking about and broad strokes I think
these two norms encompass a lot of the
smaller norms that we often focus on and
that we often see decaying in
democracies in crisis so one is what we
can call it mutual toleration the norm
of accepting the basic legitimacy of our
partisan opponents not treating them as
treasonous subversive otherwise beyond
the pale so I'll come back to this in a
moment so that's the first one the
second norm is a less familiar one
perhaps well one we call the norm of
institutional forbearance or using one's
institutional prerogatives with
restraint not deploying the letter of
the law and
ways that undermine the spirit of the
law so if you think about presidential
impeachments Senate approval Supreme
Court nominees the filibuster court
packing presidential pardons if
politicians use any of these
prerogatives to the hilt exploiting the
letter of the law to maximum partisan
gain our system of checks and balances
would quickly descend into dysfunction
and chaos so Paraguay and style and
Pietschmann Argentinian style court
packing these are actually perfectly
legal in the American context so it's
not the Constitution that prevents them
its underlying norms of mutual
toleration and forbearance so
institutional forbearance again the norm
of not exercising a formal right of
Praga tiff just because you can this
these are this is crucial I believe that
argue for democratic stability so the
question then becomes are these norms
weakening and if so why so I think
they're in fact warring sides as
probably everyone here would agree these
norms have been quite viable in American
history but they are now being
undermined and we I think driving this
is as we've heard in a lot of the
presentations today is an erosion with
emerges of a particular form of partisan
polarization so Democrats and
Republicans despise each other and we
all are citing the same study that Adam
mentioned where Republicans you know and
Democrats say five percent say they
would be displeased if they marry each
other in 1960 today it's fifty percent
you know this pew study again others
have cited you know fifty percent of
Republicans Democrats say they're afraid
of each other so we have not really seen
this kind of this level of partisan
animosity since the end of
Reconstruction in the United States I
mean we have seen this before of course
and this kind of partisan animosity is
something that we it's familiar to all
of us who study democracies in crisis in
other parts of the world so this isn't
really a traditional left-right
polarization I'm gonna kind of give my
own spin on this year it's often about
race religion and culture it's about
identity it's about way of life it's
existential so this particular form of
polarization that erodes democratic
norms in the US and then it does so in
the following way norms of mutual
toleration
and forbearance serve essentially as the
soft guardrails of democracy they
prevent normal and healthy political
competition from spiraling into partisan
fights to the death and so of course as
I've said America hasn't always had
these norms actually you know beginning
in the early 18th century Democrats and
Republican our federalist and
Republicans viewed each others as
treasonous enemies the u.s. didn't have
these norms between the 1850s in the
1870s when the country descended into
civil war but beginning in the 1880s in
the late 19th century Democrats and
Republicans pretty broadly accepted one
another as legitimate rivals and refrain
from destabilizing acts of
constitutional hardball so there was no
impeachments there was no successful
court packing senators are judicious and
largely refrain from acting unilaterally
to circum to with presidential
appointments presidents were acted with
restraint outside of wartime so the
checks and balances basically worked but
things are changing a large faction of
the Republican Party now questions the
legitimacy of their partisan rivals they
describe Democrats as traitors not real
Americans many questioned whether Barack
Obama was a legitimate president so this
kind of again this kind of this kind of
partisan animosity if view your enemy is
an existential threat justifies
violating norms of forbearance and if
you think that your enemy is a partisan
is an existential threat then you're
willing to use any means necessary to
remove your enemies from power
if you view your energy your parties and
rivals as a threat to your way of life
then this again justifies abandoning
forbearance so I think early signs of
this or the Clinton impeachment in 1998
the Texas redistricting case in 2003 was
a kind of an interesting example the
deployment of the filibuster as an
obstructionist tactic the use of
government shutdowns and threat of
defaults as a tool of partisan warfare
and finally I think most egregiously the
2016 Senate's refusal to allow President
Obama to fill a Supreme Court vacancy
this was an act without precedent in the
United States since 1866 so again our
democratic norms have been roading for
the last 25 years and our goal really is
to introduce
these terms these terms into our
vocabulary to think about norm breaking
mutual toleration and forbearance and
their presence aids Democratic survival
their absence their kind of them it
gives rise to the mirror image their
absence so that gives rights a different
set of norms mutual intolerance and
instead of forbearance constitutional
hardball while you play to the limits so
when these norms of mutual intolerance
and constitutional hardball proliferate
democratic politics become unhinged
marked by no holds bar conflict deadlock
and dysfunction so you know is America
then on the verge of democratic alliance
I'm not so pessimistic outright
democratic breakdown is unlikely our
institutions are certainly more robust
than they are in Hungary or turkey there
is really no comparison but neither on
the other hand do we think that the
checks and balances will save us and
this kind of leads to a third
perspective I think a third scenario
given the diagnosis when you imagine a
future for American politics we kind of
think of other countries that operate
with that kind of democracy as a
low-grade fever where one that's marked
by continued partisan animosity more
departures from political conventions
but most importantly increasingly
institutional institutional warfare in
other words politics without solid
guardrails so even if President Trump
fails to consolidate authoritarian rule
of some kind I think you know if we
think about what kind of politics this
looks like and try to imagine this the
United States and what to try to imagine
what is politics without guardrails look
like we can consider North Carolina
today so North Carolina is a classic
purple state with a diversified economy
its wealthier more urban and more
educated than most other southern states
yet despite this or perhaps because of
this over the last seven years North
Carolina has become what Jedediah
Purdy's is called a microcosm of our
country's hyper partisan politics and
growing distrust so partisan warfare is
intense
constitutional hardball is rampant he's
racially gerrymandered districts the
2013 voter law
fights over stacking election boards and
out an effort by outgoing governor in
2016 hamstrung his successor impact the
state's executive branch this is a
glimpse of what state-level politics
looks like without power
one could imagine this taking place at
the national level so just I'll conclude
then with this thought Louis Brandeis
once called America's States the
laboratories of democracy today they
become a nemedians this is the
laboratories of authoritarianism and
it's here we can see America's future
possibly thank you our final panelist is
Tim Snyder who is a professor of history
at Yale okay thank you very much Susan
thank you all for including me in this
community as as you'll know from the the
brief but entirely sufficient
introduction I'm not a political
scientist I political science and you
can test me if you want but I'm not a
political scientist and this is going to
this is going to be I think essential
for the argument that I'm gonna try to
make about about democracy and how we
might think of what's going wrong with
this thing that we're calling American
democracy so because I am a historian I
think a lot about time and the way that
I would define the value of a democracy
is as a producer of time what democracy
does is that converts almost magically
are unstoppable capacity to make
mistakes into a sense of continuity
about a political regime right that's
what democracy does it produces a
certain amount of time and that's it's a
virtue but it's also democracy's
vulnerability because if you can get to
a situation and I'm going to argue that
we're getting towards one where people
start to think about time in a different
way time not as something which goes
forward predictably but time is
something that loops around and makes
cycles if you get to that tipping point
that can then double down and hurt
democracy so in other words if the thing
you're calling democracy is flawed for
whatever reason in such a way that it
produces
a sense of Doom rather than a sense of
progress at a certain point that could
be the thing which brings democracy down
now the only way to make this argument
is to introduce time as a variable if
you insist a time is something which can
change in people's minds in most social
scientific analyses time is in the
background we take for granted that it
moves forward that it's measurable and
so on that is itself a historical
artifact of the of the moment that we
are in if the question is whether we're
entering other moments or not we have to
open up how we think about time and
consider that that might be changing
okay so to make this case I'm going to
start with two methodological points
about this thing we call American
democracy and then I will move to the
organ without time and then I will draw
a conclusion about what this means for
comparisons with the past so
methodological point number one is we
should be very careful about defining
the system that we have now as a
democracy when you look at it from any
kind of external point of view the fact
you know you ask if it's representative
most people in this country don't vote
in most elections and those that do
consistently don't have their policy
preferences translated into policy in
another country we would see both of
those things as as major warning signs
if what we're meant to have is a
representative democracy it's it's it's
you know they think we take these things
for granted but it's very weird that we
have registration that we have Tuesday
voting that we have an electoral college
that the Senate is lined up the way that
it does that we have the gerrymandering
that there are ten million American
citizens who are legally disenfranchised
from the system again all of those
things if you looked at it from if you
looked at another case a historical case
in 1928 or a foreign country in Asia
those things would spring out at you as
reasons while you're not looking at a
fully democratic system and that's not
to mention the limitless money in
politics which I think an objective
observer would usually mark as a sign of
oligarchy so I would characterize our
system as a mixed oligarchic Republican
system in which we use democracy in some
parts of government
as a succession principle something
something like that now the second
method Lodge up why is that important
it's important because it helps to focus
what we're thinking about because we
could be asking the question is
democracy failing alright another way to
ask that would be is the non-democratic
part of our system succeeding to which
the answer I think is fairly clearly yes
if our focus is on the head of state or
on the on States and I completely agree
with this emphasis on the states then
what we can see is that the non
democratic parts of the system are doing
quite well
it's the non democratic parts of the
system which permit the election of mr.
Trump it's also the non democratic parts
of the system which create the de facto
one-party rule that we have in places
like like North Carolina okay second
methodological observation has to do
with the unit level on America this
thing this thing called America when we
consider democratization as a good thing
we have no trouble imagining that
democratization is an international
phenomenon where we're actions taken in
the US would then have positive knock-on
effects otherwise we have to do the same
thing when we consider D democratization
we have to consider the possibility that
there is a but there is a brown
globalization or there is a reverse
globalization however you like that
events beyond the United States can have
a material effect on the United States
itself whether we like it or not and
most of us don't like it prefer not to
face it we are almost certainly in a
situation where the actions of a foreign
government determined to our head of
state is if we were looking at another
country again we would have no trouble
saying ah that means that country is not
completely sovereign we don't like to
say that about ourselves right because
we're inside the system but given that
the man I mean I won't go into all of
the ways that Russia affected the
outcome of the election we're learning
more about them all the time but been
writing about it for two years but it
but it given that the man won by 70
thousand votes scattered over three
states if they had any influence at all
they most likely tipped it in his favor
we don't like that fought right because
we're Americans but if we were looking
at a different country we would say okay
that's a country which is tipped into
some kind of half sovereignty which i
think is accurate for us whether or not
you accept the half sovereignty terminal
the methodological point I want to make
is that we have to consider this not
just as Americanists and as compared to
this but as Susan Hyde was suggesting a
different way as students of
international relations what happens
inside the United States it doesn't just
have consequences for others it also
works the other way around and this goes
right down to the technical details for
example in an ogee mabuse's paper about
the tape scandal in Poland right the
tape scandal in Poland took place at two
restaurants owned by a consortium
connected to a Russian mobster said
Russian mobster is also the boss of
felix tater who is the person who was in
charge of bay rock who is the person who
rescued donald trump and made him a
public figure in united states which
leads to the earlier point about
criminal takeovers of democracy if you
look abroad in beyond your own country
you will often notice phenomenon like
mafia democracy which you might not
notice if you were only looking inside
inside your own country okay so those
are my methodological points I wanted I
want to pick up on North Carolina
because I think North Carolina suggests
I agree with you completely suggests a
way that things might be going I'm going
to characterize it in a slightly
different way and return to the idea of
sub all turns the subalterns in the
United States and the chief the chief
the chief agents of identitarian
politics in the United States are of
course American whites and the big
confusion among American whites is
between citizenship itself and and being
white and the reason why this confusion
materially matters is that when your
state becomes when your state or your
country state in the sense of North
Carolina or state in the sense of
federal government becomes a one-party
state you don't notice that anything has
happened because you don't make the
distinction between your race and the
populace or the citizenry as a whole
right so rare is the white North
Carolinian right at least of one one of
the two parties who will say well it's
it's okay that my party's in power but
it's wrong that we've transformed our
system into a one-party state now if
that can happen on the scale of a state
it can probably happen on other scales
as well and of course then I'm gonna
know the first thing that you know one
of the important things that in addition
to the things that Daniel mentioned that
the North Carolina State Legislature
does is it it goes after its own state
education system which was
on world scale remarkable and now will
not be again such for unfortunately for
a very long time
which leads me into my point about about
time escapes so I want to now try to
consider a number of the points that
were made here and in earlier panels for
example by Professor Sikorsky in a
slightly different conceptual apparatus
one which has to do with how we think
about time let me start with factuality
which Susan Hyde very helpfully
introduced in order to think that you're
moving through time in a forward
direction you have to believe that there
are facts that connect you to the world
around you and to the people around you
and that the apprehension and discussion
of those facts can lead to meaningful
action that is that is that that is an
Enlightenment assumption that probably
most of us here take for granted but
which is by no means a feature of the
world it's a feature of our experience
in the world and it can be broken if you
move into a world of epistemic pluralism
where there's no longer a broad
consensus not only on the facts but
about whether in fact there are facts at
all then the sense of moving forward in
time becomes much more difficult
discussion becomes very difficult as
some of you might have noticed and in
addition to that common action on the
point about trust I think is extremely
well taken without a sense of factuality
it's very difficult for there to be tour
there to be for there to be trust so
that is one thing which breaks us away I
think is breaking us away from a sense
of time moving forwards another is a
group of factors which were mentioned in
in earlier panels which again I'm going
to characterize in a slightly different
way you all little literature better
than me but it seems to me the one the
one factor there one corrala which
actually Trump's whiteness or or
right-wing ideology when predicting a
trump vote in a county where Trump
voting increased over Romney voting from
12 to 16 is reduction in levels of
health right
not bad health but most precisely people
whose health was getting worse at the
county level tended to go significantly
from Romney to Trump and this was most
significant by the way in five states
that switched and so it's a factor to
which one might want to pay some
attention the economist was quick off
the mark with this and then there was a
paper a week ago in public
very of science some bye bye-bye waspey
at all about this and what why am i
mentioning this because it seems to me
that this factor of people not a
people's lifespan shortening but in
voting Republican because of it or
people's health getting worse and voting
Republican because of it or at least
along with it correlates with these
other things that we've been discussing
for example lack of mobility right
radical income inequality means lack of
means lack of mobility that's the thing
which this with this Chetty study has
established which I won't belabor
likewise lack of mobility as such is
strongly related to lack of social
mobility if you're between 18 and 34 in
the United States you are you are most
likely living with your parents it's
more likely than any other arrangement
which means that literally you have not
moved right lack of geographical
mobility like worsening health like
shortening lifespans like lack of social
mobility works against a sense of time
which allows you to think that time is
moving forward right and so the time
escapes start to change now how does
this work in politics in politics it can
be it can be you can be channeled moved
incorporated exploited however you
prefer by politicians who talk in terms
of a different time scape so for example
make America great again is a time scape
which doesn't refer to a better future
it's a time scape which loops back to an
unnamed and mythical past right so now
there are studies now about what make
America great again means for Americans
for example Taylor at all in the Journal
of applied research and memory cognition
finds not surprisingly that Americans
define the moment when America was great
in the past as the moment when they were
young right
which is funny but I think it's also
politically very significant because it
refers us to a certain political style
which I'm going to call the politics of
eternity or the government as being
rather than than doing because one of
the things about youth is that
government can't give it back to you
right I mean whether wherever we are on
the span of like how much government
should do not do can we will generally
agree that government cannot in fact
make you young again right so this is
funny but it's also revealing because
the pot what I'm gonna call the politics
of eternity the politics of cycling back
to the past rather than imagining of
future is precisely about defining
political problems in fictional terms
and therefore in irresolvable terms so
if what you want out of politics is to
be young again you might keep voting for
that promise but government is not going
to give it for you and can't I will now
give you a more serious example one of
the things which distinguishes white
trump voters from white Clinton voters
is that a significant majority of white
Trump voters in a very small minority of
white Clinton voters it's an interesting
difference a significant majority of
white Trump voters believe that White's
face greater racial discrimination in
the United States than blacks do now
that is interesting but it's also
interesting politically because that's a
fictional problem if you are white and
you believe that your problem is that
you face Greater racism then black
people do again that is not a problem
that government can solve right it's an
in it's an because it's a fictional
problem now I'm trying this is not meant
to be funny it's meant to define a
different political style a Timescape in
which government doesn't promise you a
better future but instead regularly in a
cyclical way mentions the things which
irritate you which are important to you
which cannot be solved the politics of
doing rather than being if that seems
imaginary consider the first year of the
Trump administration there is no
legislation which is going to make any
of these kinds of voters it's not going
to speak to what we would regard as
their interests or even to an ideology
right
um the two major initiatives are take
health insurance away from people which
is precisely interesting because it's
people who needed the health insurance
most who were the swing group which
brought him into office right that's the
first one and the second one is tax
regression right
the second major policy initiative his
tax regression precisely taking income
away from poor people and giving it to
richer people that's it in the landscape
of the first year those are the only two
things neither of those things can be
thought of as creating a future right
those things if anything only makes only
make matters only make matters as one
might see it worse so where does this
where does this lead us to the first
thing is I'm gonna referring to to where
reception Dvorsky ended up it may not be
that the thing we have to worry about is
whether mr. Trump will fail I mean I
don't think he's actually after success
in the normal liberal sense of the word
I think he's after failure I don't think
they intend to make policy which makes
life better for their constituents I
think they're moving very consciously
towards a different kind of policy um I
think it's a mistake
therefore to refer to this as populism
because in American tradition anyway
populism means you're against the elites
but you still imagine the government is
going to do something for you I think
we're in a different territory I think
we're in something which is more
accurately characterized as say to
populism where you you are against the
elites right but you don't expect
government to do anything for you in
fact you kind of want government not to
do anything because that reinforces your
beliefs about the way the world works so
where does this lead us this is my final
word where does this lead us on the
question of of comparison right so what
I worry with when when people say well
it's it doesn't line up well to the
interwar cases there are difference
between US and Nazi Germany what I were
with is about that is the implicit
conclusion that therefore everything's
a-okay right everything's not a okay
just because it's not February 1933 and
thoughts of Germany I think the way to
understand the comparisons is more as a
source of normative
action right I'm not gonna make that
case now because it's the case I made in
the book on tyranny it's not that where
we are now is going to inevitably lead
to czechoslovakia 1948 or you know
germany in 1933 it's that those regime
changes or the witnesses to those regime
changes give us useful and timely advice
about how to head off regime changes in
in rule of law states I think the
comparisons are most useful in that way
most useful is a general guideline that
globalization's can crash
most of our comparisons are about the
first globalization crash we're now in
the middle we're now in the middle of
number two what I think is that we can
move away from democracy we can learn
away we can learn from other people
while we're doing didn't try to resist
it even though where we're going is
going to be somewhat different I mean as
for me where I think we're going or
where we seem to be going is is
something like you know oligarchy with
just enough fascism to get by as a kind
of lubricant and and the and the way
this would look would be not so much the
creation of something new but just the
dissolution of what we have right and
not I completely agree with the point
not mobilization but demobilization are
only very occasional mobilization like
very occasional marches very occasional
violence but mostly the mobilization at
atomization and what's worrying about
that is that then you know implicitly
the people who in some of these
presentations were counted on to come
save us right the economic elites
whoever they are that the economic
elites can be on the same side that you
you can be an economic elite and you can
think in you know environment Germany
you can be the economic or in Italy you
can be the economic elites and you can
think rightly or wrong you can think
wrongly we can outwit these guys maybe
in America you're the economic elites
and you think correctly you can outwit
these guys but the outcome still isn't
democracy right if you continue to have
the kinds of drift that we're having
with the outcome still to democracy it
might not be anything that has another
dramatic name but it's not necessarily
democracy so the the point that I'm
trying to make is that we're at this
historical moment in the sense that not
just that great things are at stake and
that in that in the actions and
Institute
that we take now make a lot of
difference but also historical in the
sunset the way people are thinking about
time is changing I mean if that tips if
that if we tip from one way of thinking
about time to another if I'm right that
there is such a tipping point then we're
closer to dramatic change than other
kinds of indicators might suggest okay
thanks thank you for those amazing
presentations I think that probably we
could re title this whole conference how
scared should we be and this panel in
particular you know sort of how
terrified should we be and I think the
reason we're seeing a lot of answers to
that question that kind of vary across
the spectrum from you know completely
terrified to only mildly concerned is
that we really don't know I mean who
knows you know that's sort of the point
no one knows how history is going to
unfold we've certainly been surprised by
it in the last year and not just in the
last year so the answer to the question
is not is not no and I like to tell my
students you know I asked them a
question I say that's a real question
not a professor question you know we we
really don't know and so if you're like
me at all you you go back and forth in
your own mind over even over the course
of the day I wake up in the morning and
I think oh you know it's gonna be okay
and then by you know 3:00 in the
afternoon I want to crawl under a pillow
and just you know be one of these actors
who's stayed away from Rome for the
whole whistling period so so we have we
do have kind of a range of responses and
one of the inspirations for bright-line
watch is that you know you look for
signs of what is going to happen and the
last thing you want to do is see the
sign in the rear view mirror we don't
want to be treating in retrospect at the
signs we don't want to say well it
really was the moment when Judge Garland
didn't get a chance to be confirmed or
it was the moment when you know fill in
the blank when things really became
irreversible and and democracy died or
became severely eroded in the United
States in a way that would be very very
difficult to recuperate over any
meaningful time period so
I have some some questions I remember
that you folks are writing down
questions and filtering them to headman
who's standing over to the side we have
a few questions I like a two-door I'm
going to take some moderator prerogative
enact ask a few questions but I'm
mindful of not taking too much time
because I know that there will be more
questions from the audience and that
these were highly provocative and
interesting presentations so just just a
few questions for Nancy you and there
the concept of distancing which which I
took to mean and I've taken from your
early earlier work to mean that even if
my ally even if the person who I'm a
elite political actor and someone who
I'm in alliance with violates a critical
norm or constitutional feature I will
join the effort to punish that actor but
I'm thinking about another kind of not
distancing but let's call it
constitutional action and I've I'm
thinking about this in part because
seeing our tutor this morning thinking
about his fascinating retrospective
considerations of what happened in Chile
there were moments in the sort of
slow-moving debacle of Chilean politics
where it went from being a long-standing
democracy to being a coup and a military
dictatorship that lasted for 17 years
and was extremely repressive and harsh
there there's the sense of you know
moments when say the Christian Democrats
might have said it's good for us if this
happens but it's really it's a it's a
danger for Chilean democracy so that's a
slightly different concept I think
that's putting the long-term health and
viability of the constitutional order
ahead of immediate partisan advantage
and I wonder whether in the cases you
examined and more to the point in
American politics today you see room for
those kinds of moments of constitutional
action on it your presentation makes me
think that Trump is Fidesz and piece
right that we're sort of we you walk
through the actions that those
governments amazingly parallel kind of
template's as you described them and it
makes me think that we're sort of only
halfway there so the courts are
politicized well you know Melania is not
making judicial appointments yes or I
guess it the real equivalent would be
mrs. pence so the media in the United
States is harassed but there aren't
really formal constraints that have been
imposed for the most part yet
and the question then is again this this
issue of what are the signposts and when
do you see them in in Hungary and Poland
2010-2015 was it predictable were there
you know forward-looking intellectuals
journalists concerned citizens who saw
these things coming or or were they
really surprises questions for sort of
this is sort of Susan and Tim but well
Susan mostly I it's it's you both raised
in your presentations the very important
point that what we are observing is
taking is unfolding in an international
context and what we do influence is what
other democracies do and likewise what
they do influence is what we do and I
guess I'm looking for any hope in that
so instances in which we might learn or
be or be forewarned or take actions
drawing on international contemporary
international events that that might
help with the situation here there were
I recall with the French election there
was some speculation that it didn't help
lepen to have a Trump out there that
perhaps that gave that gave some french
voters pause Daniel you it was
interested in the so the the sort of
problems of lines being crossed of norms
being violated and the examples you gave
were pretty much on the Republican side
and I so our colleague Jacob hacker has
written a lot about asymmetric
polarization I wonder if you think this
is an asymmetric problem or if they're
symmetric more along the lines of what
team or Quran was talking about this
morning if there's a kind of symmetrical
equilibrium that we've that was sort of
a bad equilibrium that we've entered
into Tim I am it's mind-blowing to think
about the you know the sort of social
construction of our sense of time and
and and how that influences politics on
the other hand I'm very struck by you
know the make America great again
narrative so that means he you know the
the the the slogan is collectively sort
of doing what you say we do as
individuals thinking that there's a you
know there's an adolescence or a teenage
period of early 20s sort of in in our in
our national so I'm equivalent to that
in our national history that is a moment
we want to get back to and that strikes
me as setting up setting the government
up for the setting Trump up for you know
greatly disappointing his constituents
for some of the reasons act reasons you
gave and although I take what you say
that perhaps you know the the the goal
is not success on the Ute and the usual
metrics that politicians use such as
high popularity when the next election
comes around in re-election so those are
some questions maybe we could just get
to them while while people in the
audience are filtering out any other
written questions that you want to have
a so yeah I I'm delighted that you asked
this question about distancing in the US
and whether there could possibly be a
different kind of distancing here
because I I was struggling with that way
myself as I was writing this the kind of
distancing that we saw in interwar
Europe where political elites were
facing fascist parties were engaging in
violence gave them a less ambiguous
signal than we're getting
here you know if mobs are killing people
you know that wrong has been done if
you're talking about violations of
constitutional principles or norms that
fight is is much much more ambiguous and
so distancing under those circumstances
is much harder and so frankly I'm still
grappling with the idea that how that
concept can be transferred to this kind
of system but there's no doubt that
battles over the constitutional norms in
the courts would be a place to start
that would be an arena for distancing
but it's going to be much harder here
except that I am assuming that money
still has a huge amount of importance
universe politics and that if you if if
the most dynamic sectors of our economy
can get behind some sort of distancing
and realize that they don't need the
nationalism especially or the xenophobia
that's embodied in the particular kind
of challenge we have which doesn't
involve actual killing yeah
then I think that that it is still
possible but that the battles may take
place in the court and that's part of a
historical continuity but not completely
so it was was what happened in Poland
and Hungary predictable um it was I mean
this is you know - this is basically the
death of a democratic there's a
chronicle the Democratic Death Foretold
um and it was predictable because you
know the leaders were very clear on this
right they wanted not just to remake
policies but to remake the institutions
of polish and Hungarian democracy to
better serve national interests right
this was very much you know making
Poland and Hungary great again secondly
there was precedent right the
institution's had not been impervious to
this before there's been put the
polarization of the judiciary in the
past there was a previous attacks on the
media this was just a much more
concerted effort um and third I think
will response important was that these
are parliamentary systems and in times
past these fairly fragile governing
coalition's I will kept these parties
from fully exercising their Prague
and now in the absence of either in
opposition or coalition partners they
were able to do exactly what he said
they would so serious question for me
was what basically what's the hope from
thinking about this isn't international
events both u.s. you deserve in other
countries in that other countries are
affecting the US and that was a very
difficult question I have lots of things
that I might say I mean one thing to
just note is part something that I don't
think isn't a viewpoint that's it's
going to be presented much at the
conference which is sort of Mia culpa
from some of the IR scholars with who
are really promoting open economy
politics Pro globalization stuff which
is just that you know the the embedded
liberal liberal liberal compromise that
we knew about and we have known about
for a very long time was not
successfully implemented in the US and
that that both economically and
culturally maybe maybe a fault and is
maybe something that policies
prescriptions could deal with right
their policy that others have have
potentially thought about I guess the
other thing that is not really hopeful
but I think something that I skipped
over in my remarks because I was 10
which has just said when I very much
interested in how countries react to
international pressure to look and act a
certain way right and so some autocratic
posturing that I think we are seeing now
might be for short term sort of applause
and political gain rather than like it
might some of it might sound worse than
it actually is which is not really that
hopeful but I do think that there are
incentives that that some leaders that
we see throughout the world to act you
know more more totalitarian more fascist
more you know they sort of take these
these dances that are that are quite
extreme because they know they will get
attention for taking those those dance
which is not entirely good news but I
think can be interpreted as something
that is maybe slightly less nefarious
and the extremely clever long-term long
game autocrats that it's referencing who
are able to abide by the rules of the
game up right up until the moment in
which they they break with them right so
I think that that is a long term in the
long term I'm more worried about that
sort of strategy rather than the sort of
splashy head like grab bean you know
attacks in the media and that's not sort
of thing which are consequential but I
think not quite as nefarious as some of
the other strategies that one could
imagine and that are harder to observe
unhappy yeah so two thoughts one
directly on your question on the
asymmetric polarization no I I mean I
think that the record shows that it
began on the right you know and you know
people often date this the Gingrich
revolution and kind of change tactics in
Congress and Orrin Mann and Ornstein and
the work on the US Congress have kind of
shown this but it you know it's not it's
not only Republicans who are vulnerable
to this I mean Harry Reid's use of the
filibuster in the early 2000s against
Bush I mean this is clearly another
instance of this and that I guess that's
what's dangerous is that is that it mate
you know it doesn't at some level you
know begins on one side but then when it
escalates and it becomes a kind of
spiral that's exactly exactly the
dangerous scenario even the dilemma of
course is you know we should stay
high-minded and continue act with four
born before Barents in the face of
somebody who's not I mean it's like
going into a box you mean with one one
hand tied behind your back does that
really make sense and I guess my thought
on that is that as long as there are
Democratic channels still available
that's the way to go I mean you know
this is the right answer but that's
that's that's kind of how I think about
it I just wanted to say something also
on the distancing and learning because I
think there is actually something that
can be learned about other cases of dis
distancing and just you know just
recently in the last two years I mean
what's striking about the Austrian
elections last year of presidential
elections and the French presidential
elections in both cases in the Austrian
case the Catholics didn't make it to the
second round and they and a lot of
Catholic politicians endorsed the Green
Party candidate for president in France
fiown and endorsed that you know the
right
- right candidate endorsed McCrone
rather than lepen and so both cases
there's instances of distancing kind of
on the right - against the far right and
so we can learn from that and I think
one of the interesting things is why in
these countries this has happened the
waters in the US this hasn't happened
and I think part of the reason is in a
in a multi-party system in Austria and a
two tiers you know with a runoff system
and in France there's a history of this
and in both instances people were in
Austria they refer back to Kurt Waldheim
and say well you know we have learned
from this in France there's the
experience of father lepen and dealing
with father lepen and so I think you
know if the idea is that you know the
u.s. we just didn't have we haven't had
experience with this and there's
possibility for learning and this is
kind of where you know human action
actually can make a difference so people
could learn from we can learn from our
mistakes and my guess is next time
around you know hopefully people learned
something right so there's something I
learned from other cases as well okay so
there were the the question about any
hopeful things internationally and then
the idea of making America great again
it cannot lead to disappointment so
internationally I'm just gonna take a
step back and make the point that I
think the winning the Cold War both the
idea and the fact has turned out to be
very poison chalice for us so the idea
that therefore there were no
alternatives
I think stultified our political debate
precisely about alternatives and made
inequality much worse in this country in
the last quarter century and the reality
of the end of the Cold War was also bad
for us because one of the reasons we had
civil rights in the welfare state was to
compete with not so much with the
Soviets but to respond to their
propaganda and without that challenge we
drifted in another direction so that's
just I mean that's just by way of making
oneself conscious so that one can learn
things well could we have learned I mean
the book that I'm that I'm finishing now
is about this it's about the last five
or six years not starting from us but
starting from Russia with the idea that
most of the things which happened here
which seem surprising to us are just
more sophisticated versions of things
which happened in other countries which
we didn't recognize at the time so I
mean here I'm 5050 there are a lot of
things we could have learned for
Russia and Ukraine between 2011 and 2015
but we didn't learn any of them um
and the consequence was that in 2016 in
my world at least it was the Russians
and Ukrainians who were jumping up and
down saying you know Trump is possible
this is how it works in other people's
worlds it would be the African Americans
but there are plenty of segments of the
pocket or the renegade Midwesterners
right there were various demographics
who said Trump was gonna win but the
Russians and Ukrainians said he was
gonna win and they had a reason
no um people there are people there are
positive exceptions like Peter
pomerantsev in his book nothing is true
but everything is possible which is you
know on its surface a book about the
media in Russia ends that book which
concludes in 2014 ends that book by
forecasting that that combination of
media unreality and political
authoritarianism is going to come to the
UK and to United States and then there's
brexit and then there's and then there's
Trump so and then there are people like
pet rock Rocco in Hungary you know who
runs political capital who does who do
Studies on directed unreality right
foreign projections of unreality in the
Czech Republic and Slovakia and those
things are useful for us to read because
the things that were happening gotten
further in the Czech Republic and
Slovakia and Hungary then here
nevertheless started to turn up here in
2050 so yeah I mean analytically we can
definitely learn from others and of
course civil resistance is something
that we can learn from other people
right we can swallow our pride and
realize that there's been a lot of
successful civil resistance movements in
other countries and that the social
science on civil resistance is actually
very mature the second point on whether
some of these some of these voters will
be disappointed because they imagine a
better world in the past and they're not
going to get it I don't think so and
I'll tell you why I think I mean there
there will be Republican voters will be
disappointed with Trump but that's a
different set of Republican voters there
are two sets of Republican voters there
are the ones who own house doesn't have
money in the stock market and are the
ones who don't own houses that don't
have money in the stock market the ones
who own houses are gonna be disappointed
when the stock market crashes and that's
not gonna have anything to do with these
narratives that I'm talking about
and I don't treat them as the critical
bloc of voters because they went for
Romney - right they did they didn't
change anything but these folks the nine
million people who voted for Obama and
then
for Trump or the people whose health is
getting worse but voted for Trump the
people in Michigan Wisconsin West
Virginia Ohio Pennsylvania who swung the
election
these folks I don't think can be
disappointed in that way that that's my
point you know it's you want to be young
again but you know at some level you're
not going to be young again you'd like
the person who tells you look great but
you know at some level it's not true
right and that's how that no look for
you it's true you're like 15 but but I
mean the general right you know it's not
true and that's how this kind of
politics works it's not by the delivery
of goods it's by the regular delivery of
affirmation as against someone else
we're where white Republicans become in
political science terms the slope the
identitarian subalterns who are
expecting to own the state but what they
only expect from the state is that they
own it
that's it they're not expecting that
it's going to do anything for them the
other thing I want to say about making
America great again that links back to
the other point is that the make America
great again does have a specific
historical referent not for us for us
it's about being young again that for
mr. Trump it's about the 1930s or the
1920s it is a it's a revision of the
1930s as being a time where we didn't
have a welfare state and where we didn't
go to war against Nazi Germany right
that's what America first means America
first is Deutschland uber alles in
English America first means we have more
in common with Nazis than divides us and
there is you know the fact they did they
commemorate Holocaust Remembrance Day by
saying other people suffer besides the
Jews which is like commemorating the
fourth of July by talking about French
independence I mean it's true that there
are like other possible references in
history but like the holiday is for one
of them and there are a number of other
examples of this how they're trying to
undo a certain American myth and what it
comes down to is that we used to think
the 1930s were a bad time to be learned
from and now we're being instructed not
just in America this is international in
Russia Poland Hungary and also
implicitly by the fullness and island
France said by the brexit movement in
Britain we are we were being instructed
the 1930s were a good time to which to
which we should loop back
I have some questions so this is a
question for Susan Hyde and Anna G B
while the EU is powerless not able and
willing to move effectively against
democratic erosion how successful have
other regional organizations around the
world been to fight forms of democratic
erosion eg Mercosur a you just one
question at a time uh yeah I think so I
think we will see how far behind we get
on that yeah yeah I mean the so there
there's some empirical work on this that
other people have done and and you know
it's very hard to separate from the
international environment entirely right
so I don't know who I should but
basically I I think that the the
European Union and other regional
organizations most of which in the world
have a stated preference to support
democracy have some ability to do
something right now right I mean there's
no reason why the US needs to be the
only country that is willing to stand in
defense of democracy and and
increasingly I think others are stepping
into that role what can they do you know
not much but a little they can they can
sort of make clear that this is a value
that the groups of countries definitely
support I don't know that they can do
anything for the u.s. specifically the
case that were most concerned with today
but in smaller countries they certainly
have made it clear that Jews are
unacceptable for example this is already
one of the biggest moments we've seen in
recent memory on this front is that most
countries that have coos many of them
have been pro-democracy coos right that
they're not against democratically
elected leaders they're against
basically authoritarian leaders we've
seen a few of these but even those have
been on pretty strict timelines for
democratic elections following those so
you know we'll see I'm not super
optimistic that they're the saviors of
us democracies certainly and I would say
that knew the EU shizuka-san was
familiar with isn't captain some ways
responsible for the rights of the
populace right because and they run up
to you accession in 2004 there's
basically this elite consensus among all
mainstream parties that the EU was this
fantastic good that premarket was
wonderful and free trade and everything
else have went together as a wonderful
package and the only parties that
criticizes consensus or the populist who
at the time we're getting you know five
percent of the vote and it's after the
accession when it becomes apparent that
neo maybe this there was some room more
for criticism
it's the populace who make hay out of
every single
some deleterious effect of free trade of
the EU and so on and they're the ones
who then come to power on the basis of
this elite consensus and now anytime
that the EU speaks against these parties
they point to it as this is further
severe negation of our national self
interests that the EU is prompting so we
now have to you know go to our loins and
defend against the EU okay this is a
question for the panel in general and
Nancy bur mayo in particular you say
that the tendency what can you say about
the tendency of citizens to vote along
personal political issues ie those
heavily influenced by cultural
predilection predilections such as gun
control or abortion rather than in the
interest of democratic norms
not much so what one thing I think that
we don't fully appreciate that is that
at least going back to the 1930s
earliest opinion surveys thirty percent
of Americans are authoritarian I mean I
think you know if you look at who you
know father Coughlin had thirty percent
of the vote George Wallace had thirty
percent of the vote you know support in
opinion polls McCarthy had up to forty
percent support you know this is there's
a kind of strand in the electorate that
I mean you know I this is a bit
provocative I you know I don't have
details you know add an attitude data
but these they supported authoritarians
and so the issue is not what you know is
the American electorate becoming more
authoritarian the issue is how do you
prevent that portion of the electorate
and those tendencies from putting
somebody in leadership positions and so
until 2016 we had a presidential
selection system that kept that served
as a gatekeeping system and kept these
kinds of dynamics out of the top
leadership positions in the u.s. say a
few words about that but I think the
question is actually really important
whoever asked it all right because it's
forcing us yeah I think you're asking us
to to think about these small these
issues that seemed small in our abstract
discussion of democracy but actually
loom very large in the minds of
individual voters and gun control is a
wonderful example of that so political
elites to really have to do more
research on what makes certain issues
salient and what makes certain issues
Trump all of the other much more
important issues like health care at the
polls and motivate you know a trump vote
and but I just I think social science
can be an answer to that
first of all identifying those voters
and then targeting those voters and in
an alliance with moderate politicians
changing their minds and changing the
salience of issues in people's heads I
think it can be done with the media
if we're just not doing it so do you
disagree because I think you know gun
control or abortion our democratic
values right these are things that
political parties have traditionally
espoused I mean the Republican Party has
espoused it and there's nothing you know
there's nothing inherently wrong with
being pro-life or promotion or non
democratic about those stances right I
think you know what I'm more concerned
with is the the statistic that the
Daniell brought up which is that it's
not just the United States if you look
at you know Poland or hungry or France
in the last elections there's a steady
35 to 40 percent of the electorate that
is willing time and time again to plump
for authoritarian populist right-wing
nativist etc to parties and so the
question is how do you contain that yeah
I don't think it's I don't think it's a
question of persuading I think it's a
question of containing well I certainly
don't want to say that all of those
positions of the abortion position is
anti-democratic I'm just thinking about
the salience of
issues as someone approaches the polls
so they can say this candidate like
Trump for instance this candidate is
clearly anti-democratic and repulsive on
many issues but I really give priority
to anti-abortion and he appeals to be an
anti-abortion candidate so I'm going to
vote for him that's the that's the sort
of calculation that I think demands more
research and more thought on the part of
politicians but there's certainly not
especially an issue like abortion that's
not an anti-democratic issue I think so
this is a question for Daniel's if lat
but Tim Snyder might also reflect on it
how and why were those norms of mutual
tolerance and forbearance built in the
1880s through the 1900s what lessons
does that period have for for for us
today
ya know it's it's a it's a tragic story
in fact and then and we dig into this in
our book and this is kind of more a
discovery after admit as somebody who
didn't spend my life studying American
politics I think the norms of mutual
toleration and forbearance were built on
racial exclusion you know it's the end
of Reconstruction 1890 the failure of a
voting rights bill the lodge act that
allowed Southern Democrats and northern
Republicans to get along so you know
what do we do about that I mean at some
level these so-mei I hesitate even to
call these Democratic columns these are
norms of stability
forbearance a mutual toleration so the
real dilemma I think we fit in at some
level one can think that you know the
post 1965 rule there's one in which
racial inclusion of making our political
system finally democratic really after
only 1965 I would argue has generated a
backlash which now threatens those norms
and so the dilemma that Democrats face
you know with it with a small D is how
do you reconcile these things can't can
a political system be built that is both
democratic inclusive as well as one that
sustains these norms because
historically they have not there's a
tension that there's really a tension
there's a just following from Daniels
point we did the United States undertook
two experiments more or less
simultaneously and they were I don't
think there were two experiments that go
well together the first was the
experiment which I think probably none
of us would call into question of
actually trying to make the country
democratic by allowing its citizens to
vote right 1965 is clearly an important
step towards American democracy which
again I would emphasize American
democracy is and remains an aspiration
but 1965 is an important step towards it
but not long after that about 15 years
after that we began the experiment of
inequality which we are still in the
midst of professorship gorski's charge
of the gap which is from the economic
policy something it's a
that this shows that the gap growing
from 1980 between productivity and wages
right and the experiment that we've
conducted on ourselves since 1989 about
what what it means when you say there
are no alternatives
those two experiments have been
happening simultaneously and so on the
American Left when I talk to people on
the American Left which I do know all
the time
there's this constant disagreement about
whether it's a race or whether it's
inequality and I just I don't see why we
have to choose between those two things
it's both and the way they work together
is that if white people feel privileged
then they react to inequality laughs and
in a way which is louder and which might
be more disruptive of the system than
others but the inequality to the way to
which they react is nevertheless real
right so that the racism may be harder
to get a handle on and the inequality
may be more tractable by policy
instruments so we have lots of questions
unfortunately thing we're gonna have to
do it just a couple of more so this is a
question for Susan Hyde you emphasized
the demand side of the information
problem but what about the supply side
how worried should we be about state
media like Tennant sorry I don't think I
read that right media tendencies like
Fox and how do you compare to other
cases like Venezuela or Italy yes state
media tendencies media like tendencies I
guess yeah I mean there's there's an
abundant you know there's an abundance
of information right now right it's not
that people can't access accurate
information it's it their self-selecting
into inaccurate information and I think
one can talk about the supply side of
this issue as as a contributor to how we
got here but I'm not sure that it
matters in terms of where we go from
here if that makes sense so once you get
into a space in which people are just
unwilling to look at the same sources of
information and many people may be
unwilling to consider objective
information or know how to judge whether
any
piece of information is objective I feel
like the demand side is just something
we understand a lot less well than then
we understand the supply side so because
of the individual access to to the
Internet to lots of sources of
information and because of the lack of
trust in all institutions I think also
expert institutions right those
individuals that might be perceived as
providing expertise on any given topic
and I think that confidence in their
their opinions has also been undermined
already we don't trust expertise we
don't trust objectivity we don't trust
science we don't you know all of these
things are undermined that to me I mean
I feel like just the demand side is is
broken enough that fixing the supply
side at the moment is not going to
change that problem so I'm sort of
evading the question of it okay last
question and this is directed to Nancy
burr Mayo but others on the panel may
want to address it as well focus is on
importance of distancing by elites and
optimism is based on the idea that US
democracy does not present an immediate
threat via redistribution to elite
interests yet earlier presentations levy
she wore ski suggests that the lack of
progressive redistribution is
undermining confidence and democratic
institutions
is there an irreconcilable difference
here over weathered redistribution
counts as a threat or an asset to
American democracy I think there's an
important distinction between
redistribution and actual property
seizure and revolution and we are
clearly in remedying the inequality that
we talked about in an earlier panel
would not require revolution if which
require redistribution of the old social
democratic component and I think that
folks in Silicon Valley are probably not
even worried about that I think they
could handle it and I think that I
haven't seen survey research but maybe
some of you have done it I'd like very
much to look at the values of the young
entrepreneurs in the tech industry and
to see whether they would in fact halt
much more redistribution than we have
I'd love to see that data I sense that
there's probably more room there than we
might anticipate and certainly more room
than there was in fascist Italy yeah
comments on that last yes there you go
no but it's it's just fall short of
revolution and it falls short of backing
anti-democratic action on the part of
truck so but it's basically buying
social goodness sure well I want to
thank our panelists very much for a
fascinating session
[Applause]
[Music]